Clint the first of five remote and
inhabited islands of which we know
virtually nothing this is why we're here
to survey in document one of the last
paradise on earth our science team is
surveying organisms from the smallest to
the largest from microbes to corals to
sharks jen smith takes hundreds of
photographs of the bottom to understand
what lives here the divers work along a
transit line a tape stretched along the
reef davida Buddha count the abundance
of every coral species while another
team surveys the fish populations our 16
person team completes about 50 dives
every day providing a complete picture
of Flint's coral reef